what about on that cultural level we
have the sad story
of bella thorne i don't know who bella
thorne is i've never seen bella thorne
in any sort of
tv show or movie but i am told she's a
very famous tv
and movie actress now she's also a
pornographer
how'd that happen here's the quick
rundown of the story it shows you
just about everything that's wrong from
the personal to the
to the public political level in our
culture
bella thorne sent nude photos to her
boyfriend
electronically those photos got hacked
which always happens when you're always
liable for that to happen and if you're
famous it certainly will happen
when you are when you are in the public
right so she
gets hacked this guy was extorting her
said he was going to leak the photos
so she started an onlyfans.com account
onlyfans.com is this website
that allows anybody to become their
own pornographer and make money selling
nude photos and videos and otherwise
degrading themselves
so she started at onlyfans.com to leak
the photo herself
she made one million dollars in one day
and she made two million dollars in one
week
she was already a millionaire but she's
making a lot of this money
now she's supposedly a victim here
because someone hacked her photos
but whoopi goldberg a left winger on the
view
had the audacity to say you know if
you're famous
you should use a little bit of prudence
if you're famous you probably shouldn't
send nude photos because those photos
inevitably are going to leak
if you're famous i don't care how old
you are you don't
take nude pictures of yourself you only
want to share with one person but she
should
listen when they're hacking you they're
hacking
all of your stuff so whether it's one
picture or a million pictures
once you take that picture it goes into
the cloud
and it's available to any hacker who
wants it and if you don't know that in
2019
that this is an issue you you
i'm sorry your age does not you don't
get to do that
i gotta tell you i kind of like whoopi
goldberg even though i know she's a left
winger and sometimes she has these
fits of of politics on on the view
but she does have a kind of basic
conservatism she realizes
you know you think you take that photo
and it's private it's not private
when you take a digital photo it's never
private when you go on onlyfans.com
that's not ever private
anything on the internet is public the
only question is
who's looking at it and how many people
have seen it so far so if you're famous
and you don't want these nude photos to
get out there
just don't take them pretty simple right
this we used to say this to people like
hey
don't create pornography of yourself
that used to be
not just an acceptable point of view
that used to be very good advice
bella thorne was furious she said shame
on you i don't want to go on the view
anymore because i don't really want to
be beaten down
by a bunch of older women for my body
and my sexuality
blaming girls for taking photos in the
first place is sick and honestly
disgusting no it's good advice
it's good advice let me reiterate
whoopi's brilliant advice
ladies do not take nude photos of
yourself do not take them
do not send them to that boyfriend that
you really like where you're sure you're
going to be together forever and
he would never do anything wrong with
them do not upload them to the cloud
even though they're going to get
uploaded to the cloud the minute you
take them just don't do it
why would you do it what's the point of
doing that you will only regret it
i got i got a message from someone who
had an only fan's account this was a
message that was sent in
through the website not through that
website through my website and she had
this problem pertaining to her only fans
account and
was trying to work her way through it
and i i said okay i'm happy to try to
help you sort out this
tangential problem but here's the first
problem you're on only fans get off of
only fans
don't do it there is no good that can
come of that there is only harm that can
come of that
you will regret every moment that you're
on there the money isn't worth it
the money isn't where it's not even that
much money i guess for for bella
thornton if it's two million dollars
that actually
gets to be part of the problem but it's
not just
don't do it i guess you're not allowed
to say that these days
because that's it's somehow feminist to
get women
to to sell their bodies
and it's misogynistic to tell women
not to be degraded and objectified
that's the
wait a second i'm seeing some i'm seeing
a little illogic in that
in that framing but actually this this
money is a little bit of the issue
because that's not the end of the story
here
thorin puts these nude photos up the
customers apparently felt that
thorne was not sufficiently nude in the
photos and they had paid 200
for the photos pretty expensive photo so
they demanded a refund and i want to
take a pause here
everything is public on the internet
everything okay
why on earth if you really wanted to see
a nude photo of bella thorne
wouldn't you just like wait for some
other guy to pay 200
and then for that photo to inevitably
leak we know the photo's gonna leak
the original photo leaked and that was
on her private cloud account
you know it's gonna get out there why
would you pay the 200 these people not
not thinking with their uh upper upper
regions
so they got upset they wanted a refund
but now you're talking about two million
dollars going back and forth on this
website so only fans said okay this is
too big a problem
we're in a cap how much you can charge
at fifty dollars
okay fine enough but now the other
pornographers are upset
the other women or sometimes the men who
are prostituting these women are very
upset
that the cap is going to be 50 bucks
this way we're making more money so what
happened bellathorn apologized
bellathorn said i wanted to bring
attention to the site the more people on
the site the more likely the chance to
normalize the stigmas
and in trying to do this i hurt you i've
risked my career a few times to remove
the stigma behind sex work
porn and the natural hatred people spew
behind anything sex related
hatred they spewing hate i don't know
that it's hatred certainly
exploitation and degradation but i don't
know if it's hatred i wrote and directed
a porn against the high brows of my
peers and managers
because i wanted to help with the stigma
behind sex i am a mainstream face and
when you have a voice a platform and you
try to use it and helping others and
advocate for something bigger than
yourself
again in this process i hurt you and for
that i'm truly sorry
i'm sorry women i'm sorry that i in any
way discouraged you from degrading
objectifying and selling yourselves
please go back and objectify yourself
sell yourself please
everybody involved in this entire
situation
is doing the wrong thing except for
whoopi goldberg whoopi goldberg is the
one person who gets it
and she didn't even go that far she
didn't say all girls should not take
nude photos of themselves
she said girls who are famous who know
they're going to get hacked eventually
shouldn't take nude photos of themselves
how how do we get
from that culture to a good
self-governing
society that that recognizes virtue and
can have logical conversations
you can't that's the problem that's the
problem i'm not
i'm using this only fans bella thorne
thing as one example
obviously there are many issues beyond
sex
sex is the most scintillating of them
probably but this gets into fraud
this gets into other personal relations
this gets into how we do business
in the country this gets into how we
look at our local communities
this looks into the relationship we have
to labor this looks into the
relationship we have to slave labor
overseas if you don't have a robust
moral sense
and you don't actually practice virtues
and you don't even understand the
argument for practicing the virtues
as many people here other than
apparently whoopi goldberg does
you can't have a self-governing country
your country is only as good as the
people
your ability to regulate your country is
only as good as the
people's ability to regulate themselves
so what do we do some some conservatives
throw up their hands they say well
there's no way to legislate morality
that's obviously bs
all laws legislate morality all laws
make moral arguments
right down to parking meters you can't
have the whole
the way you legislate is by making moral
arguments for the laws
and then enforcing those laws so of
course you can now you don't want to
have a tyrannical
regime that is uh that is undermining
public morality which can happen as well
i think we're pretty far from that at
this point though
why don't we take back our politics in a
way that can go in and say hmm
shouldn't be doing that shouldn't be
doing this we
forget onlyfans.com which certainly
should be heavily regulated probably
into the dust
probably just outright banned because
also what are the what are the safety
guards here how do we know that people
under 18 are in on this website
of course they're on this website so
there are many
legal ways to go after a website like
that but we
have such a loss of respect for law
law and order in this country that we
can't even tell
murderous rioters on the streets to put
the guns down
ted wheeler won't do it he's fanning the
flames
democratic party fanning the flames of
this encouraging him
saying please go out there mob them get
violent
that's not just a personal problem
that's not just a cultural problem it
all ties into this bigger problem we're
trying to we're looking at it in these
little pieces
we're just seeing the trees here you got
to zoom out and see the forest
the personal problem as the left says
the personal problem is the political
problem
and the political problem ties in not
just blm not just antifa
it's the democratic party it's the whole
edifice in the face of that
where do you stand in november what do
you see the stakes as in november
getting more intense and more intense
and more intense
we always hear this the most important
election in our lifetimes
when your opponent tells you that when
they tell you what they're going to do
to you if they get back in power what
they tell you what they're going to do
if they don't get back in power
believe them i hope you enjoyed that
short segment from the michael knowles
show be sure
to check out the full episode linked in
the description or
download the podcast wherever you listen
to podcasts
[Music]
you